how are you feeling right now good ready
to not have a baby in my belly anymore
me too me too
mommy's tired baby machine baby number
four correct yeah well baby number four
is here and rocking the red carpet
Hilario baldwin carried her four month
old son Romeo in a camouflage pouch
while attending a Film Festival with
husband Alec Baldwin in New York the 34
year olds yoga instructor donned a black
long-sleeved top black leggings and
matching shoes at the opening of the
Hamptons International Film Festival
posing it up on the carpet with her
hubby and looking absolutely stunning
whole area previously took to Instagram
to share how her body has bounced back
after pregnancy posting this collage of
pics with the caption the recovery from
baby number four continues she also
shared a ton of pics of her baby bump
before giving birth in May and in June
she was accused of photoshopping images
of her body prompting her to share this
video of her fit figure she captioned
the clip in part quote for those who are
saying I photoshopped how about this
Alec in hilarya also share five year old
daughter Carmen three-year-old son
Raphael and two-year-old son Leonardo
the actor also has a 22 year old
daughter Ireland Baldwin with ex-wife
Kim Basinger et caught up with a
lovebirds in May right before Romeo was
born we're gonna have three boys and a
girl and my daughter our daughter told
us every day that she's gonna have a
little sister after this one so I'm
traumatized by that mommy want another
one after this one mommy doesn't even
want to think about another one right
we'll see if she police beat him to it
we can't afford it